[Música]
ya son más de 60 los muertos por las
lluvias e inundaciones que golpean a
alemania y bélgica más de 2500
rescatistas han sido desplegados para
responder a esta emergencia que fue
calificada de catástrofe por la
canciller alemana angela mente
el primer ministro designado del líbano
saad hariri presentó su renuncia tras
nueve meses en el cargo en los que no
logró conformar un gobierno lo que
aumenta la presión en un país sumido en
una crisis económica
cubanos en el exilio salieron a las
calles de diferentes ciudades del mundo
para sumarse a las históricas protestas
que estallaron en la isla en rechazo del
gobierno el presidente miguel díaz canel
y para denunciar la represión
desproporcionada a los manifestantes
analizamos la situación en el país
caribeño
muy buenas noches gracias por continuar
con nosotros en france 24 cierre de
blanco como siempre un gusto
acompañarlos comenzamos con todas las
noticias del acontecer internacional con
las lluvias inundaciones en alemania que
han cobrado la vida de al menos 42
personas mientras que decenas continúan
desaparecidas la situación es
especialmente preocupante en el oeste de
este país donde los estados de renania
del norte-westfalia renania-palatinado
se ven duramente afectados la canciller
angela merkel se refirió a la tragedia
desde washington donde se reunió con su
modelo estadounidense de baile mi
corazón está con todos aquellos que en
esta catástrofe perdieron a sus seres
queridos o todavía están preocupados por
la suerte de las personas que siguen
desaparecidas incluyo a bélgica
luxemburgo y los países bajos que
también han sufrido inundaciones y
justamente como lo mencionó la canciller
alemana las inundaciones en bélgica
dejan también 18 víctimas mortales en
otras noticias el primer ministro
designado del líbano saad hariri anunció
su dimisión luego de no haber podido
formar un gobierno y atrás
de acuerdo con el presidente michel aún
la atención no sea esa en un país con
una profunda crisis económica social y
política y tachado de corrupto por la
comunidad internacional el informe es de
natalia plazas
líbano no encuentra salida a su
estancamiento político tras nueve meses
de intentar formar un gobierno el primer
ministro designado del país
saad hariri anunció su renuncia lo hace
después de que el presidente michel aún
rechazara su propuesta de un ejecutivo
formado con 24 especialistas
está claro que no podremos llegar a un
acuerdo con el presidente en nuestra
reunión le sugerí que se tomara más
tiempo para pensarlo si lo necesitaba
entonces dijo que no podíamos llegar a
un acuerdo por lo tanto me disculpo por
no poder formar un gobierno que dios
ayude al país
hariri fue designado en octubre con la
misión de formar un ejecutivo que
hiciera frente a la crisis económica
social política y sanitaria del país una
situación agudizada tras la mortal
explosión en el puerto de beirut que en
agosto mató a más de 200 personas y
forzó la renuncia del gobierno anterior
la negativa al gabinete será después de
meses de fallidas negociaciones y
bloqueos por la repartición de los
distintos ministerios entre hariri el
político sunita más influyente del
líbano y aún aliado del grupo chiíta
hezbollah la renuncia del líder sunita
podría dejar al país en el limbo hasta
las elecciones de 2022 y agudizar así su
crisis múltiple con una devaluación de
su moneda local del 90 por ciento el
banco mundial ha descrito la depresión
económica que vive la nación como una
las más graves de la historia moderna
esta queda entre la espada y la pared ya
que la comunidad internacional ha dicho
que no inyectará dinero al país hasta
que éste tenga un ejecutivo que impulse
profundas reformas anticorrupción
y decenas de personas la mayoría de
ellos cubanos expatriados salieron a las
calles de diferentes ciudades del mundo
para apoyar a las protestas de sus
connacionales en la habana las protestas
estallaron en rechazo del gobierno del
presidente miguel díaz canel en medio de
la crisis económica y también en medio
del aumento de los casos de kobe 19 que
ha llevado a algunos de los hospitales
de la isla al borde del colapso para
analizar lo que está ocurriendo en cuba
quiero saludar en este momento a manuel
cuesta morúa portavoz del partido arco
progresista en cuba y vicepresidente del
consejo para transición democrática en
la isla gracias por estar con nosotros
manuel muy buena pregunta cuál es la
situación actual de las protestas en la
isla y si aún continuaría más que se
sabe de las personas detenidas y cómo es
el trato para estas personas que han
sido detenidas en el marco de estas
protestas
siempre hay una tensa calma en relación
con las protestas ahora localizadas en
algunos barrios del país algunas
regiones un poco alejada los ciudadanos
continúan expresamente expresando ese
rechazo
el día 11 de julio marcando un antes y
un después ahora mismo estamos en lo que
llamamos una racha de detenciones
arbitrarias sin debido proceso a muchos
de estos jóvenes que básicamente no son
los jóvenes es básicamente participaron
de estas manifestaciones llegan agentes
de la policía a las casas tocan no
importa la hora y se llevan
violentamente a aquellos que han
identificado están amenazados de
desorden público y en algunos casos
amenazados también de vandalismo ya la
fiscalía ha dicho con claridad de que
van a juzgar entre tres meses y veinte
años a los participantes más activos de
estas protestas a lo largo del yogur
ahora parece que el presidente díaz
canel está reaccionando a estas
protestas ciudadanas se estaría frente a
un algún tipo de cambio de isla
bueno yo creo que hay lo que llamaríamos
un cambio cosmético como reacción al
impacto que ha supuesto estas
manifestaciones a lo largo del país y el
régimen sorprendido en su burbuja con la
respuesta ciudadana pues ha tratado de
dar lo que llaman una especie de
jurídica para aliviar un poco la presión
de la ciudadanía sobre todo en materia
económica en materia de necesidades
básicas y autorizado la vieja demanda
que había negado la de que los exiliados
pudieran ayudar a sus familias
directamente acá lo que sucede es que
esto no va a satisfacer básicamente a
muchos de los que participaron en estas
manifestaciones porque no todos tienen
familia en el exterior
debón con una curita para tratar de
calmar la situación y al mismo tiempo un
cambio de retórica que me parece
importante porque lo que había
y presidente el día 11 de julio a las 4
de la tarde era una amenaza al conflicto
nacional manuel gracias por su tiempo
por ayudarnos a entender un poco lo que
está ocurriendo entonces en la habana
cuba y también en otras ciudades del
país
gracias buena noche el presidente de
brasil ya ir bolsonaro responde de forma
satisfactoria al tratamiento clínico al
que fue sometido tras diagnosticarle una
obstrucción intestinal y podría
prescindir de una cirugía esto tras ser
retirado de un litro un litro de líquido
de su estómago el líder de la
ultraderecha brasileña de 66 años fue
trasladado a un hospital privado de sao
paulo tras una complicación en un cuadro
intestinal se encuentra bajo observación
médica
contenido el festival de cine de cannes
drama de época sobre la fidelidad y una
cinta sobre el deseo de la juventud
moderna probaron su suerte en la
competencia veamos el informe
un drama de épocas sobre la fidelidad de
una cinta sobre el deseo de la juventud
moderna probaron su suerte en la
competencia de cannes
la directora húngara ildikó njeri
presentó ante el jurado de cannes la
historia de mi mujer una obra maestra
tanto por la forma como por el contenido
sobre la vida de pareja la fidelidad y
la confianza
[Música]
un capitán de marina decide casarse con
la primera mujer que pase por la puerta
de un restaurante la suerte recae sobre
él y si una rubia exuberante enigmática
y mundana la película sigue durante
varios años este matrimonio donde se
instala el aburrimiento y las sospechas
de infidelidad
los actores jim a ver y la francesa
léase edu forman una pareja increíble en
esta película que se desarrolla en
distintas ciudades europeas el ganador
de la palma de oro en 2015 jack odiar
regreso a la competencia en cannes esta
vez con leds olimpiada un drama sobre
las vicisitudes amorosas de tres jóvenes
en la capital francesa
las olimpiadas se desarrolla en el
barrio del mismo nombre del distrito 13
de parís sus tres protagonistas dan
rienda suelta a su libido desbordante en
esta intriga tortuosa algunos se
enamoran otros prefieren revolotear de
flor en flor y otros encuentran su rumbo
miramos
esta película se distingue por una
fotografía impecable en blanco y negro y
una banda sonora firma de ajn uno de los
compositores franceses de música
electrónica más prodigiosos del momento
hasta que el informativo continua
[Música]